EXPELLING 60 DIPLOMATS.
WE IS THAT AND MORE.
YOU DON'T WANT TO MISS OUR
BREAKING NEWS OPENING MONOLOGUE.
THE LEFT WING MEDIA REACHED A
BOILING POINT AND UNHINGED
INSANITY.
THIS IS TRUE FOR FAKE NEWS CNN.
THEY HAVE BEEN OBSESSED WITH THE
PORN STAR STORMY DANIELS AND
CLAIMS SHE HAD A ONE TIME
ENCOUNTER WITH DONALD TRUMP 12
OR 13 YEARS AGO.
YOU DON'T BELIEVE ME?
TAKE A LOOK FOR YOURSELF.
>> DETAILING ON NATIONAL
TELEVISION AN INTIMATE
RELATIONSHIP WITH DONALD TRUMP
AND THE EFFORT TO CONCEAL IT.
STORMY DANIELS.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE BRIEFING
EXPECTED TO BEGIN ANY MOMENT.
THEY WILL FACE QUESTIONS ABOUT
STORMY DANIELS.
>> THE STORMY SAGA TAKES A
DRAMATIC TURN AS THE PORN STAR
SPEAKS OUT ON HER ALLEGED AFFAIR
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> PORN STAR STORMY DANIELS
BREAKING HER SILENCE ABOUT HER
AFFAIR WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE MOST
SERIOUS LEGAL ALLEGATIONS THAT
STORMY DANIELS FACE.
>> STORMY DANIELS.
YOU HAVE HEARD A TON ABOUT THAT.
WE HAVE TO SEE WHAT THIS
INTERVIEW IS ABOUT.
>> IS IT POSSIBLE TO COME UP IN
THE STORMY DANIELS LAWSUIT?
CAN SHE SAY THIS LAWYER IS
INVOLVED WITH DIFFERENT THINGS?
>> COULD THIS BE THE LAST NAIL
OF COSTIN.
STORMY DANIELS IS CAUSING FORME
WEATHER.
>> STORMY DANIELS CLAIMED
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD HER BULLYED.
>> DOES STORMY DANIELS HAVE THE
PRESIDENT'S NUMBER?
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP MET HIS MATCH
WITH STORMY DANIELS.
>> HOW IS STORMY DANIELS
WEATHERING THIS?
>> WE ARE HEARING QUITE A BIT
FROM STORMY DANIELS.
IN HER OWN WORDS IS NOT GOING
ANYWHERE.
>> STORMY DANIELS HAS A GOOD
LAWYER.
>> THE PORN STAR TELLING THE
TRUTH?
>> STORMY DANIELS IS ON A TEAR.
>> QUICK PREVIEW OF STORMY
DANIELS'S INTERVIEW.
>> BREAKING NEWS.
>> STORMY DANIELS.
STORMY DANIELS.
>> THE REASON HE CAN'T ENGAGE
WITH STORMY DANIELS IS BECAUSE
SHE HAS HIS NUMBERS.
>> Tucker: CNN IS NOT JUST
FOCUSSING ON STORMY DANIELS.
THEY ARE GIVE AIR TIME TO THE
CLAIMS MADE BY A FORMER PLAYBOY
PLAYMATE
PLAYMAT
PLAYMATE CARREN McDOWELL WHO HAD
A CREEPY INTERVIEW.
>> WERE YOU ATTRACTED TO HIM
ISN'T SEX WAS CONSENSUAL?
DID HE HAND YOU MONEY?
DID HE BRING UP HIS WIFE OR TALK
ABOUT HIS CHILD?
WERE YOU IN LOVE WITH HIM?
>> I WAS YES.
>> DO YOU THINK HE WAS IN LOVE
WITH YOU.
DID DONALD TRUMP SAY HE LOVED
YOU?
HOW DID YOU FEEL BEING IN HIS
APARTMENT?
DID HE COMPARE YOU TO HIS KIDS?
DID HE USE PROTECTION.
>> Sean: LAST NIGHT ON "60
MINUTES" ANDERSON COOPER SAT
DOWN FOR HIS MUCH ANTICIPATED
INTERVIEW WITH STORMY DANIELS.
DESPITE ALL THE OVER THE TOP
CLAIMS MADE BY HER LAWYER AND
THE MEDIA OBSESSION, COOPER'S
INTERVIEW FELL FLAT AND CAME OFF
CREEPY.
>> YOU TOLD DONALD TRUMP TO TURN
AROUND AND TAKE OFF HIS PANTS?
>> YES.
>> DID HE?
HE TURNED AROUND AND PULLED HIS
PANTS DOWN.
HE HAD UNDERWEAR ON.
I GAVE HIM A COUPLE OF SWATS.
>> THIS WAS DONE IN JOKING
MANNER?
>> YES.
>> DID YOU GO OUT FOR DINNER?
>> NO.
>> YOU HAD DINNER IN THE ROOM?
>> YES.
>> YOU HAD SEX.
YOU WERE 27 AND HE WAS 60.
WERE YOU PHYSICALLY ATTRACTED TO
HIM?
>> NO.
>> DID YOU WANT TO HAVE SEX WITH
HIM?
>> NO, BUT I DIDN'T SAY NO.
I AM NOT A VICTIM.
>> IT WAS CONSENSUAL?
>> IN AN INDUSTRY WITH CONDOM
USE IS AN ISSUE DID HE USE ONE?
>> NO.
>> HE WANTED TO CONTINUE TO SEE
YOU?
>> FOR SURE.
>> Sean: ONE TIME CONSENSUAL
RELATIONSHIP.
WAIT UNTIL YOU SEE THE INTERVIEW
FOOTAGE THAT DIDN'T MAKE SERE
FROM "60 MINUTES" OVERTIME.
IT WAS POSTED ON TIME.
THIS IS TABLOID TRASH.
>> THEY WANTED ME TO MAKE A
MOVIE.
>> I SAID NO.
>> WHY?
YOU HAVE SEEN HIM IN WAYS OTHER
PEOPLE HAVE NOT?
>> CORRECT.
THEY ASKED ME TO DESCRIBE THAT.
>> HIS PRIVATE PARTS.
>> Sean: DESPITE CLAIMS OF
STORM'S LAWYER THE ONLY NEWS
WORTHY MOMENT WERE HER CLAIMS
THAT SHE WAS THREATENED BY AN
UNIDENTIFIED MAN.
THAT WAS NOT BACKED UP WITH ANY
EVIDENCE.
NO EVIDENCE WHATSOEVER.
HE GOT THE EMBARRASSING DETAILS
OF A ONE NIGHT STAND FROM OVER
12 YEARS AGO.
EVEN SOME OF THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA THEY ARE EXPRESSING THEIR
DISAPPOINTMENT BY ANDERSON HARD
HITTING JOURNALISM.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I THINK PEOPLE THOUGHT THERE
WOULD BE A SMOKING GUN HERE.
DID WE MISS SOMETHING?
>> AS A YOUNG LAWYER, I REMEMBER
BEING TOLD NEVER OVER-PROGRAMS.
-- OVER-PROMISE.
UNDER-PROMISE AND THE JURY WILL
LOOK POSITIVE ON YOU.
THIS ATTORNEY DID THE OPPOSITE.
OVER-PROMISED.
SENT OUT TWEETS ABOUT PICTURES.
HE TOLD US 2 WEEKS AGO SHE WAS
THREATENED WITH ASSAULT AND WE
WOULD FIND OUT MORE ON "60
MINUTES."
WHEN WE FOUND OUT NOTHING NEW ON
"60 MINUTES."
>> WHAT ARE YOU WAITING FOR?
WHAT IS THE TRIGGER THAT HAS YOU
RELEASING THE PHYSICAL EVIDENCE?
>> I ASKED YOU WHETHER THIS WAS
ANY EVIDENCE, TEXT MESSAGES OR
PHOTO EVIDENCE THAT VERIFIED
THAT STORMY DANIELS HAD THE
AFFAIR YOU SAID THAT'S A
QUESTION THAT MISS DANIELS WILL
HAVE TO ANSWER.
CUT TO LAST NIGHT.
ASKED DIRECTLY ABOUT THIS ON "60
MINUTES" AND SAYS MY ATTORNEY
HAS INSTRUCTED ME NOT TO ANSWER.
DOES SHE OR DOESN'T SHE HAVE
THIS EVIDENCE?
>> Sean: HELL FROZE OVER.
I AGREE WITH LIBERAL JOE AND THE
"TODAY" SHOW SAVANNAH GUTHRIE.
AFTER CREEPING INTERVIEWS WITH
STORMY DANIELS AND McDOUGAL, IT
LOOKS LIKE ANDERSON COOPER
TURNED INTO CNN'S JERRY
SPRINGER.
IT'S A COMPELLING COMPARISON.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU TOTAL DONALD TRUMP TO
TURN AROUND AND TAKE OFF HIS
PANTS?
>> YES.
>> DID HE?
>> YOU ARE YOUNG AND LIKE TO
HAVE FUN.
WHAT IS THE STORY HERE?
>> OH, LORD.
>> YOU HAD SEX WITH HIM?
>> YES.
>> DID YOU WANT TO BE WITH HER
BOYFRIEND?
>> NO, IT WAS A ONE TIME THING.
>> DID YOU WANT TO HAVE SEX WITH
WITH HIM?
>> NO.
>> HE WAS JUST A CUSTOMER,
RIGHT?
ARE YOU INTERESTED IN BEING WITH
HIM?
>> HE TOOK ME HOME.
>> YOU WORKED IN AN INDUSTRY
WHERE CONDOM USE IS AN ISSUE.
DID HE USE ONE?
>> NO.
>> DID YOU ASK HIM TO?
>> YOU HAD SEX WITH HIM?
>> YEAH.
>> Sean: JERRY SPRING CREEPY
ANDERSON COOPER COULD BE COMING
FOR YOUR JOB.
CNN RAN IMAGES ALL DAY OF STORMY
DANIELS WITH MCDOUGAL.
CARON
CARO
KARO
KARE
KAREN
KAREN.
THIS IS A HUGE DOUBLE STANDARD
IN THIS COUNTRY.
ALLEGATIONS FROM A PORN STAR WHO
HAD A ONE TIME CONSENSUAL AFFAIR
WITH DONALD TRUMP.
THE EVENING NEWSCASTS ON NBC,
ABC, AND CBS DEDICATED A
WHOPPING 40 MINUTES OF AIR TIME
TO TRUMP ALLEGATIONS OF A
CONSENSUAL RELATIONSHIP.
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA IGNORED
SERIOUS STORIES OF ABUSE.
BRODERICK AND PAULA JONES WHO
ACCUSED BILL CLINTON OF GROSS
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT.
IN 1994 WHEN PAULA JONES CAME
FORWARD ABOUT DETAILS ABOUT BILL
CLINTON EXPOSING HIMSELF TO HER,
CBS AND NBC IGNORED IT.
ABC GAVE IT 16 SECONDS.
AND:
IF FAIRNESS TO BRADLEY WHO
PASSED AWAY HE DID AN INTERVIEW
ON "60 MINUTES."
CNN DIFFERENT THEN AND NOW.
IN 1998 WHEN NEWS ABOUT
BRODERICK'S SERIOUS CLAIMS HE
WAS RAPED BY BILL CLINTON IN THE
'70s.
ABC AND CBS DID NOT FIND AIR
SPARE SECOND TO COVER IT.
LISA MYERS FROM NBC BOOKED THE
FIRST INTERVIEW WITH JUANITA.
FOR OVER A MONTH THE CHIEF
PREVENTED FROM THE INTERVIEW
FROM AIRING BECAUSE THEY WERE
THEY WERE UNABLE TO CORROBORATE
HER STORY.
WHEN THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
COVERED THE STORIES OF BILL
CLINTON'S ACCUSERS, THE
REPORTING WAS DISMISSIVE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT SOME OF THE
CLIPS PROVIDED TO US THANKS TO
THE MEDIA RESEARCH CENTER.
>> YES, SHE IS NOT A CREDIBLE
WITNESS.
>> I THINK SHE IS A DUBIOUS
WITNESS, I REALLY DO.
>> A LOT TO TALK ABOUT THIS
WEEK.
INCLUDING THE SEXUAL HARASSMENT
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
>> IS SHE NOT TRYING TO
CAPITALIZE ON THIS AND TO PROFIT
FROM IMPUGNING THE PRESIDENT?
>> I HAVE TO PROFESS COMPLETE
CONFUSION OVER THIS ENTIRE CASE.
WHY THIS IS EVEN A CASE.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK OF HER
STORY?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE IT AT ALL.
NO EVIDENCE TO BACK IT UP OTHER
THAN VERY CIRCUMSTANTIAL.
WHAT SHE MAY NOT OR MAY HAVE
TOLD HER FRIENDS AT THE TIME.
IN A DEPOSITION THAT NEVER
HAPPENED.
THE STORY DOESN'T DESERVE TO BE
DIGNIFY
DIGNIIE
DIGNIIED
DIGNIIED B
DIGNIIED BY
DIGNIIED BY B
DIGNIIED BY BEI
DIGNIIED BY BEING
DIGNIIED BY BEING DI
DIGNIIED BY BEING DISP
DIGNIIED BY BEING DISPLA
DIGNIIED BY BEING DISPLAYE
DIGNIIED BY BEING DISPLAYED.
>> Sean: THEY DISMISSED CLAIMS
AGAINST BILL CLINTON.
ABC'S FORMER CLINTON THREATENED
TO END SOMEONE'S CAREER IF THEY
WENT PUBLIC WITH BILL CLINTON'S
AFFAIRS.
>> IT WOULD NOT MAKE IT TRUE.
IT'S [BLEEP].
IF YOU WENT ON THE RADIO AND
SAID BILL CLINTON IS THE FATHER
OF AN ILLEGITIMATE BLACK CHILD,
PEOPLE WOULD THINK YOU ARE
CRAZY.
YOU WOULD NOT WORK AGAIN.
YOU WOULD BE INTERESTS
EMBARRASSED.
PEOPLE WILL THINK YOU ARE SCUM.
>> Sean: THE POINT IS THE
LIBERAL PRESS COVERED HILLARY
CLINTON WHILE THROWING HER
HUSBAND'S ACCUSERS UNDER THE
BUS.
WE'LL HAVE THE VIDEOTAPE.
>> THE TRIO OF WOMEN WHO SAID
BILL CLINTON MADE UNWANTED
SEXUAL VANCES IN THE '80s AND
90s.
HE DENIES IT.
>> WHEN IT WAS BILL CLINTON'S
PROBLEM REPUBLICANS TRIED TO
MAKE IT AN ISSUE.
IT DOESN'T WORK.
WHY WORK 20 YEARS LATER WITH HIS
WIFE?
>> I APOLOGIZE TO THOSE TRAMPS
THAT HAVE SLEPT WITH MY HUSBAND.
>> THE ACCUSATION IS
DISCREDITED.
CANDIDATE.
HE WAS NOT IMPLICATED IN ANY
MISCONDUCT.
SHE WAS NOT ACCUSED OF DOING
ANYTHING UNTOWARD WITH REGARD TO
THESE WOMEN.
>> IT'S ABOUT GROPING AND
TOUCHING AGAINST A WOMAN'S WILL.
>> AND RAPE.
>> DONALD TRUMP USING THAT WORD
UNPROMPTED DURING AN INTERVIEW
LAST NIGHT WITH FOX NEWS SEAN
HANNITY BRINGING UP A LONG
DENIED ACCUSATION AGAINST FORMER
PRESIDENT BILL CLINTON DEATH
BACK TO 1978.
>> Sean: THAT'S PATHETIC.
AND NBC EDITED THE ON LINE
VERSION TO REMOVE MITCHELL.
WHAT WE SHAO  SHOWED YOU IS
APPALLING.
PAULA JONES WILL REACT.
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA SHROUDS
ITSELF IN MORAL SUPERIORITY
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP BUT DEFEND
ALL THINGS CLINTON.
TAKE ACCUSATION ABOUT AN ALLEGED
CONSENSUAL ENCOUNTER BETWEEN
TRUMP AND STORMY DANIELS AND
TURN IT INTO A WEEKS LONG
SCANDAL.
THEY ALMOST IGNORED ALL OF THE
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST BILL
CLINTON.
RAPE, GROPING, TOUCHING.
KISSING AGAINST ONE WOMAN'S
WILL.
EXPOSING YOURSELF.
WHEN IT COMES TO BILL CLINTON,
OKAY, THEY WON'T FIXATE ON ANY
OF.
IT BUT EVERY DETAIL OF A
CONSENSUAL RELATIONSHIP AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP.
JOURNAL IS DEAD.
OUR NEXT TOP STORY THAT THE
MEDIA WON'T TALK ABOUT TONIGHT.
THAT'S THEIR NARRATIVE OF THE
TRUMP AND RUSSIAN COLLUSION
NARRATIVE SUFFERED ANOTHER BLOW.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
ANNOUNCED  THEY ARE KICKING OUT
60 RUSSIAN DIPLOMATS.
AND'S RUSSIAN CONSULATE IN
SEATTLE WAS ORDERED TO CLOSE.
THE EXPELLED RUSSIAN HAVE 7 DAYS
TO LEAVE THIS COUNTRY.
WHILE PRESIDENT TRUMP TAKES
SERIOUS ACTION AGAINST RUSSIA,
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER WHEN THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA PREDICTED THAT
DONALD TRUMP WOULD DO THE
OPPOSITE.
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS SOME
KIND OF A SHILL HEAR VLADIMIR
PUTIN.
THEY SAID MAYBE THEY HAVE
SOMETHING ON DONALD TRUMP.
>> I THINK HE IS AFRAID OF THE
PRESIDENT OF RUSSIA.
>> WHY?
>> THE RUSSIANS MAY HAVE
SOMETHING ON HIM PERSONALLY.
>> IT'S CLEAR THAT VLADIMIR
PUTIN AND HIS ASSOCIATES,
SOMEBODY HAS SOMETHING ON DONALD
TRUMP.
THAT MAY BE SOMETHING THAT TURNS
THE KEY IN THE RUSSIAN PROBE.
WHY THIS PRESIDENT DEFERS TO
PUTIN AND RUSSIA.
IF THEY HAVE SOMETHING ON HIM.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS AFRAID.
A POLITICAL HURRICANE IS OUT AT
SEA FOR HIM.
HURRICANE VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> THEY MAKE THESE DECISIONS
TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
IN A WAY THAT MAKES IT APPEAR
THAT THEY ARE HOSTAGES.
THAT HE IS VLADIMIR PUTIN'S
HOSTAGE.
>> Sean: YOU JUST HEARD IT.
FORMER CIA DIRECTOR SAID THE
RUSSIAN MUST HAVE SOMETHING ON
TRUMP.
WHY WOULD HE DO WHAT HE DID
TODAY?
I WONDER IN THE MEDIA WILL EAT
THOSE WORDS.
IF THE MEDIA'S OBSESSION WITH